salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une
vidéo un petit peu particulière voilà ça
fait à peu près un an et demi qu'on
pèche c'est quand même pas d'accumuler
de latéral droit bien sûr on est déjà
allé plusieurs fois chez le ferrailleur
mais on s'était dit qu'on irait plus et
qu'on ferait un gros tas dans le garage
pour tous évacués d'un coup donc c'est
l'idée c'est grand jour l'idée pour nous
c'est de montrer qu'on peut s'amuser
dépolluer les cours d'eau et en même
temps avoir une petite source de revenus
bon bien sûr c'est rien d'incroyable
voilà on va dire que la ferraille va
payer les déplacements et même peut être
peut payer le matos bon aujourd'hui ça
va peut-être pas être le cas parce que
nous on a décidé de faire les choses un
peu en grand et de louer un camion benne
pour évacuer toute naturelle on espère
que vous allez apprécier cette vidéo
tester jusqu'à la fin qu'on le déclic de
l'argent qu'on a réussi à faire avec la
ferraille n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit commentaire pour votre estimation
du poids et de l'argent si vous voulez
donc si vous êtes vraiment vous pouvez
directement mettre l'argent pensez aussi
à vous abonner ça nous fait plaisir et
surtout pour une vidéo comme ça un petit
peu rica pour on voit comment on payer
nos efforts ça nous donne beaucoup de
force première remorque remplie passa
pas vraiment c'est carrément 1,3 tonne
ouais voilà je sais pas combien on a mis
on va voir c'est la surprise comment on
a une tonne ouais je pense qu'on doit
les y être pas loin
d'avoir la même pas mis trop
[Musique]
est un dieu me rappelle jean de manquer
de guérison de l'union soviétique
on part pour le deuxième arrêt ouais et
ouais pas le premier à laval
on n'était pas bon qui sait en 60 kg
cela une autorité pour attraper en faire
une bonne 5 du coc
faut pas laisser ça
[Musique]
caisse enregistreuse
ça a été vite dommage
deuxième camion bien chargé encore
on fait quand même mal de la voir partir
mais bon après c'est pour la bonne cause
elle va être recyclé il aurait pu
restaurer certaines choses mais bon
c'est comme ça qu'on peut pas tout faire
non plus et c'est quand même pas mal à
nier n'hésitez pas en commentaires si
vous voyez des choses qu'on n'aurait
surtout pas dû jeter à nous faire rager
ouais
c'est mon copain était coincé tu rentres
dans l'auto mon copain est bon copain
wave a créé toutes sortes
qui vont pas nous arrêter pour le poids
d'un surchargement copains très pour la
pesée belle à une tonne une tendance
paris moi je tirais une tonne un crémant
c'est bon alors 980 quoi
voilà donc ce qui reste du tas pour le
troisième voyage moi c'est un peu sombre
on va être encore bien remplie
[Musique]
découpez les pneus cela s'arrête trop
dur
il part entière
elle tu fais quoi son total à six il ya
tout d'un coup qui s'effrite ah ouais
peut-être parce que tu es à taper avec
les manceaux de ferraille non
les deux vélos on a péché sous le même
pont ouais
c'est dommage de les bazars des mais ils
restent eux rien on sait pas trop si le
ferrailleur va accepter les roues on a
un peu la question tu dis ça pour moi
ouais puisque les roues d'habitude on
m'a dit ils viennent pas à la ferraille
je prends le temps il est rentré deux
fois déjà donc ces bizarreries savoir de
passer ma casquette voilà le troisième
camion le plus chargé en pente bon
surtout il fait l'impression de plus
chargé parce qu'il ya beaucoup de tôles
leurs gardes du corps la chorale
descendu ouais
bravant la vie pareille une tonne et une
tonne ouais
bon allez pareil aussi
par contre si vous êtes trop et que vous
êtes un chien il a en plus de
difficultés 1 est mon petit où il peut
pas aller chez faire ailleurs non ils
mangent les moules bien joué et bien
joué
bon allez c'est parti
alors donc on arrivait à 2 tonnes 480
web on pensait faire plus mais on n'a
pas fini ce mépris et prévôt 372 euros
362 jours deux tonnes
dans le détail on prépare ta [ __ ] mais
c'est bien ce prix 150 donc c'est le
prix mac on a eu le prix maximum qu'on
pouvait atteindre pour la ferraille dans
toute l'affairé des péchés mal vos
prières
donc voila le résultat un an de pecz
éléments en piles batteries
d'ordinateurs
de téléphones batterie externe des piles
de toutes tailles donc c'est vraiment
grave de trop de trucs tous à vélo
[Musique]
donc tout ça je vais l'amener à la
déchetterie c'est ça en moins dans les
cours d'eau donc bonne dépollution pour
le plastique
voilà la journée ferrailleurs tous à sa
fin yes donc on est quand même contents
du prix du chèque même si on s'attendait
à plus emploi après à savoir que vendu
coup 372 euros on n'a pas vendu tout ce
qui était moteur dont contenant du
cuivre on n'a pas vendu tous quitté
aluminium il y en a à peu près % auront
peut-être ça les amuse plus mais mais
voilà donc si on fait le décompte en
enlevant la location du camion en
enlevant les sens on arrive à environ
270 euros de bénéfices la pêche à l'un
des parents est une activité qui
rapporte mais ça ne coûte pas d'argent
si on fait les choses convenablement et
de récupérer les déchets donc ce ne sont
pas des déchets c'est valorisables c'est
ça qui est beau avec la pratique j'en
veux dire c'est ça trois tonnes de
déchets sortie d'eau qui vont servir
pour nous c'est un petit peu l'objectif
c'est un petit peu la création de
voyages à l'autre tu es bien écologique
voilà tout ce travail a abouti et d'un
côté ça va bénéficier à d'autres
personnes concernant les piles je sais
pas si elles sont recyclables dans cet
état mais dans tous les cas elles sont
bien mieux qu'au fond de l'eau n'hésitez
pas à nous donner des idées parce que
c'est vrai que ça fait parfois mal au
coeur un petit peu d'emmener chez le
ferrailleur des objets qui pourrait
resservir où il pourrait par exemple
servir pour faire de la sculpture
l'orfèvrerie donc n'hésitez pas à nous
donner peut-être des contacts des
instagram de personnes qui pour ce genre
de sculpture nous on se fera un plaisir
de les contacter et ils sont dans la
région de leur fournir de la ferraille
graphiquement pour leurs créations
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à lâcher le
petit prince tout ce bleu nous soutenir
et nous donner la force et l'envié de
continuer de sortir trois tonnes de plus
à les passer tous une bonne journée et à
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche à l'élan